it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kit
we're out come on baby
all righty then
we need to make some of these happy
kitty fight club we really do those are
my favorite teas dude that's so good i
can't believe you're still uh
let's revive hold up this totally gotta
do it still i'm gonna revive the t5
camera
i'm glad you brought up old school t fat
k yeah i've i have an update on frankit
3d okay
i want this in person okay um i know
you're in austin we'll get to that i'm
in austin and i'd love to hear about
your trip in austin i can't wait to tell
you so i've worked
very hard to get fire and kit 3d very
proud of it yes it outsold game of
thrones the name schumer show at the
time on itunes yes it's a big deal for
us i created that with our friend mitch
and we put all effort in time and i
think they're really good and that was
when we were with fox and they paid for
it so they've owned it and then i
recently found our old boss pete
valencia at uh
malibu carson coffee which is no longer
there and we'll get to that too because
i'm
not happy with it right so uh that guy
canceled my kids are heartbroken anyway
so i met pete there i was like hey dude
i would love to get find a kid back like
we made him is there a chance to get he
goes oh that's easy they don't use them
man i'll just call my old boss
he's a great guy he loves you he'll give
it back be in your inbox in no time
so that was on sunday yeah by
wednesday thursday that week they're in
your boys inbox and i text the fine kid
on the group chain i go your boy got
fine kid 3d plan is we're gonna release
it once a week throwback can't wait for
this
i even came on the show and announced it
it was braum so um
fox they they they give them to us but
one thing you should know about fox and
i i wasn't aware of this
disney owns fox right and so corporation
yeah disney owns it so then the dark
side yeah yeah the darkest side yeah so
i got a call from moana himself and he
said um
with disney right i own it yeah
that's ours
this is actually moana he goes yes and
i'm not representative for mickey mouse
and you cannot have these because he
talked to mickey mouse who talked to the
cryogenically frozen walt disney yes
okay in another dimension and he went
[Laughter]
release it it belongs to us but here's
the yes and no i like to think we're a
big deal but uh he went i'm sorry who
are you with what i think he goes what
the hell are you talking about we own
our finding his 3ds he was cool cool
we're working on
toy story 7. um what are you talking
about the caribbean pirates you know
johnny just doing a new pirates right
yeah he goes we don't give a [ __ ] about
you i know cool i know but could you
just release them so we're trying to
contact someone at disney release
business affairs they don't care no
they're just unaware of it because
they're disney that's right so it's a
little bit like calling uh avis rental
car but actually even bigger and saying
i left some sunglasses in the back seat
two years ago and i'm wondering if you
guys have them it's what it is right now
that's what we're doing oh i thought you
were saying you really legit did not
like that oh dude
only bigger than davis because it's
disney it's disney they're like oh i'm
what are you talking about huh hey [ __ ]
we're coming out with space jam i feel
like we could just release them you
can't
trust me bubba because they will they
were they have ownership they own them
yeah that would be like
that would uh obviously
on the other side of that that would be
like disney going hey we're big fans of
firing the kid
firing the kid we're gonna start posting
fire the kid on our website yeah and
we're like no you can't like yeah we can
yeah
yeah you can't steal content like that
just not the way it worked you know what
but here's the thing pete smart guy he's
like i'll figure out we'll get it done
i'll talk to my boss at fox so i'm sure
has somebody at disney and we'll get
done he's like you're just looking at a
little longer roll out some red tape
what you and i should do is march down
there to disney and go we'd like to talk
to the head of disney about releasing
our
fighter kid 3d i don't know if you know
this but speaking of disney i got in the
wrong elevator when i was shooting a tv
show there
i got on the wrong elevator you're
shooting a show at disney's yes it was
it was uh
yeah it was um
peter pan it was a sony thing but i was
always disneyland and i went up to um
i would got in the wrong elevator
and i got to the top of where the brass
is
and and in fact i believe the chairman
mr iger or some one of those guys and
imagine being the chairman of disney oh
yeah and and a gentleman uh a
strong looking 50 year old
gentleman who clearly looked like he had
had some military
experience maybe all the military
experience he had a thing in his ear and
he just barrel chested and just met me
with a smile and he said i was with
somebody else and he goes hello how are
you i hope your house your day gone i
said uh it's good he said so i was going
to help you get back downstairs because
uh uh for some crazy reason we
you came all the way up here and that's
not supposed to happen anyway with the
elevator oh wow because they have to do
a thing yeah cause you can't just so you
guys know most of those elevators you
can't go on just hit a button you have
to have a card or usually someone from a
different station goes what floor and
you go i'm here to see whatever gary v
cool uh floor 317 yes and then you you
have no control he smiled at me just
kind of how are you i hope your day's
going how's your day going good so uh
there must have been a malfunction silly
stuff we're sorry about that and i went
who's uh and he goes that's that's and
then i found that it was mr igers
i mean
imagine you're not getting up there i
mean you did i did get up there by some
first of all you were already on the
line got on the lot and then actually i
got on the building because i was there
to see somebody else who worked there so
i got lucky to get in there and then
somehow i got into the wrong elevator
it'd be funny if that security guard was
just you know he's like a five-star
general like four like seven thousand
kills on the direction and he just has a
hard-on for like snow white
well he was just balls even a little
mermaid he was such a professional that
i i felt like i was being complimented
and that that i would he was happy to
see me oh like he's de-escalating and
he's like
oh you do it yeah that's right he got in
the elevator with me and with my friend
and we were like what what's go i didn't
even know what's going on yet
and i wasn't sure cinderella cinderella
like somebody's like iger's office i
found that out and i can't remember how
but i remember being like oh that's what
so operation disney i'm gonna need you
to dress back up and try to get back on
that lot so here's where we get fire and
kid 3d i have this like saving silverman
i have the plan what's the plan
you dress up like donald duck i dress up
as mickey
and we just walk in like we own the
place
in the full get ups yeah no no no no no
no no no dude that they don't really use
those characters anymore and they're
sure as hell not letting on the mascots
from the disneyland place on the line
because they're they look not good
they're frowned upon
it yeah don't be shitty right yeah
you're gonna dress up as that french
candle guy from beauty and the beast and
i'm gonna be the big john smith guy
right
right we're gonna put a stupid candle on
top of your head okay and then dressing
that weird french outfit and then give
me your french accent it's a little
insulting give me a french accent i'm
from france uh
oh
okay
[ __ ] no try try this be our guest be our
guest
be our guest
[Music]
okay and you're the little gay camel
twink you're the beast and i'm beauty
no no no no no no well speaking of
breaking into uh buildings and being
unseen i uh i had the privilege of of
learning some special forces tactics
with a guy named tim kennedy this
weekend in austin my much tougher
brother from a very different mother
that's that's a professional as he's as
professional as he's been through all
four
sniper schools
in uh the u.s military and i believe
graduated top of his class now those
guys looked like they won me in a
carnival there i am i'm not bad there i
look a little sexy gordon ryan you look
sick um wait is that little where's
going right now gordon ryan's on my
right
oh
oh oh wow oh wow yeah yeah i didn't know
his beard was like great wow yeah he's a
savage yeah it's more blonde i thought
is it the sun
that's why i didn't recognize him like
who's the guy with the gray beard yeah
it has to be the sun no that's uh yeah
and tim told me that you know pretty
much he's never really had a problem
with anybody jiu jitsu he can he gives
everybody fits
but gordon ryan's the only guy he loses
to every single time constantly
and i was like
yeah gordon ryan yeah yeah yes we have
to that's right yeah he's our lebron
well the last time tim uh gordon just
won this big tournament and he said the
level of everything
is pathetic
and i was like and i talked to him a
little bit and i said what did you mean
by that and he goes well you know all
you have to do with those guys is
they're speaking french and all you got
to do is come in speaking japanese i
mean i said i kind of substituted that
yeah yeah he won't do that but that's
what it is it's just like once you get
them out of their comfort zone and
you're doing something they don't know
what to do but also he and they're so
innovative if they're speaking to to run
with your metaphor if they're speaking
japanese he'll do portuguese who do
french who do mandarin and do [ __ ]
and he'll also be looking at his coach
while he slowly puts a choke on you
mm-hmm it's it's [ __ ] well he's just
masters he's the best we have yeah yeah
the best we have but then he was telling
me the same thing he's like you know i'm
not trying to learn how to shoot guns
and he was a total novice it's like what
the so tim takes me i put on
tactical gear i put on bulletproof vest
helmet this is nice and cool out there
yes and this is for this this is for one
of my episodes of best of with brian
callan on youtube and so we're shooting
and he's teaching me he takes me through
a whole day
of training shooting from cars
shooting in the building going into the
building like a friday or saturday or
something this is on a sunday sir oh you
stayed till sunday that's correct sir i
had to wake up i got four hours of sleep
so now i'm there takes me through an
obstacle course the whole thing kind of
a not easy
and i then we had to
they put two they put his buddy shane
and they put a a an amazing this navy
seal long time navy seal and did all the
stuff named jeff gonzalez great guy
[ __ ] great guy
and they just are sitting in the safe
house and they they
just gonna shoot you
not with real not without not with paint
bullets or anything just gonna show you
how shitty you are and i had to hit you
would be
nothing they'd go bang bang oh well yeah
yeah i think you missed well what they
use sir
is they'll use a real live cartridge
with a with paint but it hurts super bad
oh so you were getting hit with stuff i
did not no i'm a no i'm a [ __ ] and oh
you told them not to no no they're not
going to do that with me because frankly
um i'm such a novice they're going to
hit you every time yeah and when you go
to try to clear a room i kept getting
tim killed i kept getting my [ __ ]
partner killed because it there's it's
like everything else it's
exhausting you're carrying a lot of gear
and you're
i but the point i'm trying to make is a
procedure to it too so whenever you come
into a room when you clear a room i kept
stopping in the doorway by the way and
he's like if you do it again i'm going
to kick you in the [ __ ] back you're
getting us killed you'll never stop you
go right in or do you go right outside
but you have to pie you have to vector
you have to look so think about a room
it's the corner it's open in the corner
we're in the room right now this is so
you're coming in here yes
if somebody's hiding right there with a
gun you don't see them you have to clear
they have the beat on you they got the
beat up they're what
the room you as you come through
they're already waiting for you yeah i
know and that's what those guys do what
do you do
you have to literally have split second
reflexes where you see somebody now it
could be a woman like this with a baby
but you're so on edge that you have to
see if the guys get the guy's pointing
the right play he's going to get to jump
on you so when you clear that [ __ ]
door there is that moment where you are
you are always i don't give a [ __ ] how
good you are you are always vulnerable i
was going to say because the guy with
the rifle let's say he's a bad guy right
in here he's gonna have to beat on you
no matter what every single time unless
he's just uh that's the problem so what
do you do you [ __ ]
you you get shot sometimes or you get
the jump on the guy or you do whatever
these guys do tactical [ __ ] do but and
then
when you come in the room together if i
got right i'm moving right if he's got
left he's moving left of course what i
do is i dance in the room it's all it's
by the way it's all footwork it's a
shitload of footwork which
it's all that [ __ ]
but i was just like no matter what you
do every time we were doing [ __ ] where
we drive up in a car you'll see it all
but drive up in a [ __ ] car with a re
i had i had an ar-15 with fully loaded
real bullets where i got to shoot from
the car
and then i got to exit the car while
he's laying cover it was live all live
for ammo it was [ __ ] and i was so
exhausted by the time i got on the plane
you know that that noise it's physical
it's just so like adrenaline oh dude
like in your
yes you're everything just pumping
everything like you know where you know
whether you wear you the [ __ ] out you
know you don't think about when you're
coming into a room and you're behind
your buddy
my my gun was like pointing at his head
like sweeping his
they're putting it down right now they
point like they point up and then they
and then but they're never that's part
of the training they watch it they watch
themselves on video they reassess and
they're always training always training
always training you train five days a
week when you're not on a mission gotcha
let me ask you this yeah all those you
guys are retired
well that's a complicated question
brennan this is probably a classified
question the answer to that is probably
not a lot of the guys that let's put it
this way you wouldn't be doing that if
you were out of the game
when i got there uh uh one of the guys
who runs sheepdog response is a guy
named matt
who is
well he was in a group called well it's
green beret and then he was in a group
called
delta force and then
i believe he went on to other things in
these secrets is there a group higher
than delta
uh
you're not supposed to you're not
supposed to talk about i just touched on
my [ __ ] neck yeah that elite forward
uh yeah you'd but you know just built
like a [ __ ] like like a truck it
looks like a truck they're all freaks
there are there are uh they're they're
they're our best
athletes they're the tip of the spear
they're the best the military has to
offer the us military has to offer the
best by far the best though yeah and and
lateral thinkers they're not like grunts
they they can think outside the box all
the time and they've seen so much combat
but every guy that was there
that that is there to train with pistols
and mil they're all these they're all
these guys so i i walked in in a white
t-shirt and my
my
green slacks no no you're the you're the
you're the you're the the chum in the
wild i couldn't have looked more out of
place but i'm the comedian bubba yeah
you know that though he brought 11 of
his guys from sheepdog
they're all [ __ ] dad he he's devgrew
he's delta it was just like can i tell
you i'm sure you had a great time uh
learning how to fire against like hey
let's be honest you're never gonna do
that
say tactical the all the time tactical
training i don't say complete waste of
your life but right right well we're
gonna do it but hold on yeah and this is
what drove me
nuts and again i wanted to wait into
studio uh confront you on this
brian sent me no lie
seven texts going bro we gotta move to
austin bro i need to move to austin bro
austin's so great bro awesome this and i
would just resp i wouldn't respond then
five by six month i need you relax it's
hot out there i knew it was gonna annoy
the [ __ ] it's hot out right here now and
you're drinking the kool-aid dude you're
drinking the cookie i kept sending him
text just to [ __ ] agitate him because
i knew it's the one thing you can't
stand where i was like dude
it's hot but it's it's double awesome i
would just send him dumb [ __ ] and he was
i knew he was ignoring me but he
couldn't take it finally he's like hey
[ __ ] you loved austin huh
yeah i mean i love austin i i just you
know i love la i've been in l.a a long
time i love la's pretty great yeah i
agree i mean look i like austin
it's hotter than the sun right now it's
a 110 degrees so you know it's weird
like i know that that's the one knocking
off like that doesn't really bother me
because ac right it's 222. um
i don't know i just
the taxes be better but i don't i don't
know i just have no desire
i i have a theory on it first of all it
there are great it's great food it is a
it is a it is a progressive city
right which is ironic because people go
there to get away from the progressive
mindsets
great [ __ ] coffee shops great
restaurants great people 100 music
scenes friends are there economy scenes
blowing up everything i get all of it
everything's great land's cheaper than
here 100
aubry marcus came to my show on thursday
[ __ ] love that's our boy love him
yeah uh i've been a long time since i've
seen him i had a just a great time with
them and there's every reason to move
that great people we have everything we
know everybody chin was down the move
mark said he's in yeah we know everybody
um but
uh
i feel like i my theory on it is mainly
i think people move there because
there's a romantic idea behind texas
there's this idea i'm gonna have land
i'm gonna have a well i'm gonna be
self-sufficient i can have all the guns
all the toys and i think in some in some
ways there they are that guy right there
matt that giant guy that's the that's
the delta guy the guy behind him is the
dev grew guy that guy yeah oh i hope i'm
not giving all this stuff away you're
talking about the guy that looks like
homeboy from uh avengers end game thanos
that is that thanos
by the way sir so you don't get that guy
matt right there nicest guy in the world
you don't get more elite than the drama
the big thick yeah you don't get more
elite you don't get more
like whatever you want to call the top
top of the military that's that guy yeah
and the guy behind him same thing the
guy behind him is a dev groove guy
and six four there he is two right there
yeah that's a [ __ ] great call thank
you sir that's a great call
go back again
dude
you are good with it he's even got the
stripes yeah
yeah his shoulders go on for days they
look identical and the guy behind him
sir who's about six four it's a terrible
picture of him yeah no i know they're
they're all navy season special forces
but he he went after dev grew he he went
to
harvard to the john f kennedy school
government and got his degrees the only
part
yeah
yeah so they're all great guys that's
all the whole sheepdog response team and
their wives and uh and he's got loving
guys it was such a [ __ ] blast but i
love tim tim is the [ __ ] yeah we have
every reason to move to austin but i
just i like it out here
i i i could move there i could easily
yeah i think so out of all the spots i
could move there rogan and i had dinner
on thursday and would you guys eat that
at this steak house called eddie v's
which was great and uh he's in he's
always he's all [ __ ] oh he's mr texas
he [ __ ] loves he's the governor of
texas yeah that's cool yeah look at this
couple red guys a couple red guys in
their 50s could we be any redder
did you get did rogan get out of a sauna
or something he no we were just that it
was the lighting or maybe we just ate
too much steak i don't know what
happened
yeah
these guys teeth are white yes
we had a good time we had a laugh
b can we take a little break buddy take
a break from just chatting with each
other sometimes you got to take a break
from just being awake you look rested
though daddy well i sleep on a helix mat
i knew it you freaking liar
i sleep on let me explain something
about 20 22 hours sleep on there uh
pretty it looks that way because i sleep
so well because with helix you can take
a quiz if you're a tummy sleeper a side
sleeper a back sleeper if you like it
you're a mattress firm
is it medium
same mattress for you as is for me or is
it custom it's custom why don't you just
sleep on it for a hundred nights risk
free and if you don't like it they'll
actually come and get it for you it's
completely
literally risk-free so why don't you try
that it was rated by wired and gq
magazine as the number one best overall
mattress whoa
big time i've heard of those just go to
helixsleep.com don't take our word for
it try it out 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up but you're gonna
love it so don't worry about 10-year
warranty yes just take their two-minute
sleep quiz they will match you with the
perfect mattress for your thick body
give you the best sleep of your life
10-year warranty like brian said try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up if you don't love it but
you will helix has financing options
flexible payment plans listen a great
night of sleep is not far helix is
offering you guys up to 200 dollars off
all matched orders and two free pillows
brian for the listeners and viewers of
the finally kid go to helixsleep.com
fighter
it was good to see i didn't see and the
new cap city is good i love that club is
it good it's not just good the where the
area it's in in north austin is [ __ ]
amazing yeah because it's a little off
of 6th street like it's about 20 minutes
outside of it yeah about 20 minutes and
it's uh it's just got all these shops
it's like you know it's a little bit
like um
scottsdale arizona you know oh yeah it's
in a mall like that like high-end mall
yeah like damon marcus golden goose
you'll love it i mean it's like great
restaurants and the club itself is
[ __ ] awesome but also up and running
people love comedy did rogan tell you
when uh his i think they're looking like
maybe october maybe
i think he said something like january
it's going to take a while yeah there's
a lot he has a lot he bought a theater i
know permits and everything drafthouse
he was going to show it to me and we
didn't have time we had to get he had a
show i had a show he was the draft house
oh yeah i was hoping he was going to be
able to open on thursday but then he had
to go he had a show so he couldn't do it
because the way it was too far away
well we might be back in austin soon
doing a little uh hold on anything yeah
there's a little busy one there's a
little roamer everybody keep it down
the apocalypse you missed a good
companion on saturday i heard i talked
to matrion
yeah texted him yeah he's great um eric
griffin was great eric's great because
you know i do this show flashback fights
with him i introduce them to like
fighters he has no clue about fighters
so i'll start from their very first
fight and finish on their last fight and
educate him on it and he just loves
fighting now and he's freaking into it
man look at all you guys
look at all you guys
look at maddie
i know how big matt matty might have a
fight
are you serious
he got an offer i he told me who i can't
talk about could you guys all fit in
this head do you think or
matt has the biggest head in the world
yeah i mean eric's isn't small though no
it's not
no eric is not a small man
but matt's
all muscle yeah you got a you got a
fight offer
interesting is chris a monk is he a
medieval monk
i told him he dressed like a priest
uh-huh like
a [ __ ] boy priest like the kind of guy
hold him um
looks like a priest just come out of a
monastery he looks like a priest just
for gay men that's that's exactly with
chains and [ __ ] yep it's like a mock
turtleneck that's amazing that's the gap
belontiaga collabs i get it i get it
okay
pretty intense there yeah that's fine
eric's great though i love that because
he's yeah he's so funny love him
i woke up a little news uh from my papa
early in the morning my grandma passed
away sorry about that 98. that's a
[ __ ] great i just talked to my dad so
i told you my dad because he's he was
her caretaker because she lived you know
about two miles from so he's one of 13.
so
the rest of them are spread out all over
so my dad's so close he's always been
close to his mom he was like the
caretaker so it hits him the hardest
so you know obviously he's down i was
you know he loves to work out like that
he has a geo workout today he's like no
you got to work out got it that's going
to help you get all the stress and
depression whatever it's going to help
with everything with the endorphins and
all that and adrenaline he's like no i'm
going to go today i'm like promising
you're going to go i just told him i
said
you know he was like you see me doing
better
better with it than me i was like well
it's your mom he was my grandma but i
you know i wasn't that close to her
as my gran as a kid she was great to us
and she'd watch us but um
you know i don't know as i got older and
you know some issues there but i wasn't
that close with her and then also to me
it's like 98 yeah great run dude and i
told myself amazing right i don't know
what i said the way i look at i said
yeah i'm all right i said i'm sad i've
seen i said i'm more concerned about you
i said but 98 man we should all be lucky
so lucky man 98. hey how about 80. every
day that's a good run i think about my
dad at 82. anything after 80 is gravy
that's a good run 98 daddy
that's incredible
where it gets nice is my my because my
dad is responsible for he's the power
power fraternity or whatever for it does
that do with all her real estate and all
you know monies and all that stuff and
delegate all that and she had a will so
in the funeral and all that somebody
said hey you know we're gonna figure out
the funeral you make sure you come in my
head i'm just like
man this is where it sucks with my
schedule
you know yeah it does it it it you would
go to it for your dad oh that's why i
told him i was like i was like dad
please like give me if you can give me a
heads up let me figure it out i'm
literally going for him 100 of course
he's just going for him and you know he
he that's his mom
and she's 98. and we'll think about has
to be weird you know when you're
you know you're both your parents are
dead you're you know you have no one
it's a big moment yeah that's where he's
at i remember my i've told you this
before my grandfather that i was real
close to him i was very close to my
grandmother um but i've always put death
into context you know me i i'm like no
emotion you know shut it down
and i remember saying i'm lucky i had
him for 84 years or whatever it was i
was different i felt lucky it's a great
run i had a great relation no regrets
and i put that into perspective and then
i was working out with jimmy burke the
next day
and i was like i couldn't move my body
i could not [ __ ] bend over i couldn't
like my whole body felt like i had been
electrocuted it was so weird
and i i say to him i go dude i can't
[ __ ] bend over like my legs my
everything is so tight
and jimmy goes brian you just said
goodbye to somebody you've known your
whole life and furthermore somebody you
really loved yeah but you haven't cried
and you haven't done a thing about it
social and i was like [ __ ] that's what
it is my body i was pretending that i
could handle it but my body was just
and once you said that though like i was
able to kind of start crying on the
bench i didn't cry but i was able to
kind of i cried in my sleep
i wept in my sleep it was [ __ ] weird
i woke up crying but but um
yeah my body my body let go
death is a weird thing but i also think
when he was telling me this i was i'm
around my son you know boston who's two
and tigers six and there's like so much
life there you know it's just so weird
that's what you're doing i'm staring at
them yeah i'm standing at them like
that's
that's i that's the cycle of life yeah
and that is what what one one child you
know opens his eyes while another closes
their eyes that whole idea
it is what it is it's the cycle we're
all going to be i don't think funeral
this isn't a hot take anything i also
think like the the old school funeral
where everyone's in suits it's black
everything's dark
barium like that whole that whole
tradition to me is very old school now
that's definitely happening because
you've never met somebody more religious
than my grandma which i
you know even uh when i knew she was
kind of sick i'd see her
you so religious she's like i can't wait
to get to heaven like there has to be
some peace with that where she her faith
is so deep like to her it's like yeah
dude this is this is gonna be fun like
this is the ride i'm like i'm so jealous
of that yeah that must be dope like to
have that confidence and relief where
you and maybe she's right i don't
[ __ ] know hopefully she is yeah but
she thinks you can go up and see the big
man you know that's her number one goal
so it's like i i would just i remember
being like ah that must be nice i don't
have that you know i spoke to uh
somebody who
almost died this weekend
and uh
they told me that
i said what is it done and he goes he
goes i'm not afraid of death even a
little bit anymore what do you mean he
goes because i was already dead i
remember i remember i was started to
lose my body and he goes and and while i
was dying i said this is the big deal
this is nothing it's like oh this has
been one big [ __ ] like you know the
fee the pain initially all that but he's
like this is what it is he's like i i i
and he was looking around he was going
this is [ __ ] beautiful and now he has
zero fear of it now that was him and i
you know that's that situation
but it's an interesting thing to they do
people who do psychedelics they say come
back so when you do ayahuasca
and you lose your body
and so so when people are facing a
terminal illness the biggest thing that
they go through is
like when they do a mushroom ceremony
one of the biggest things that helps
them is dealing with the inevitable
and they're just not afraid anymore but
they they say you know obviously
scientists look into an atheist look
into it so when people say oh they see a
light
they said they you know they've studied
the brain when someone's passing away
what the brain does like all right it's
go time this is you know final exit the
brain just fills the body in the brain
with uh some dopamine so you feel this
sensation of like clarity and
everything's all good which is how dope
are the body it's incredible the woman
who was calling her mama she's getting
eaten by a [ __ ] grizzly bear a
terrible story grizzly bear is eating
her legs and she's calling her mom she's
nagging because he kept coming and would
come back i guess and eat and then
finally it left and she was dying she
was talking to her mom and she finally
said oh my god wait the pain's gone
pain's gone
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine the body's
like we're gonna release some morphine
in here yeah that's [ __ ] see so now
here's a here's a spiritual idea so you
can you can describe the mechanism of
what happened scientists can describe
the mechanism of what happens okay
yes
but what's within that like what's what
what's the umbrella around that it's
like
i know what's happening to you
physically but why is it happening to
you physically what is really happening
where where are you going those are the
[ __ ] questions science can never
answer it's like well no we can't yeah
but but apparently psychedelics are not
right i i might go down the rabbit hole
of psychedelics i'm very interested you
keep saying that i'd have something
scheduled i tried to get you involved
yeah come on no i think you'd like it i
did that
saturday i know bubba and you guys stay
the night absolutely no no no i'm not
staying tonight no but it's hours right
yeah it's hours it's it's you know i'm
curious i want to go down the road i
want to do ayahuasca i want to do a
mushroom ceremony i want to do because
ayahuasca is the dmt
that'll last eight hours sometimes yeah
i'm not doing that
but what are you looking for me
you said yourself at your age like
you're not gonna have any breakthroughs
i don't know
i don't know i'm i'm you know what i'm
looking for
i'm looking to see if i can lose all my
i want to lose all fear of death
and i'm not that afraid never have been
that afraid of it maybe because i'm
naive about it or i'm ignorant to it but
i just want to see what's there i want
to see if there's a there there and you
think you're going to solve that by
doing that i had a really interesting
experience with aubry marcus this this
thursday we he came to the show and and
aubry's gone aubrey's done the medicine
for 23 years that [ __ ] has gone
down to rabbits phd phd yeah
smart day and what i thought was really
interesting with aubry is that we were
talking about spirituality and
philosophy you get me started i'm gonna
i'm gonna rattle off a bunch of [ __ ] i
read
i'm gonna rattle off a bunch of [ __ ] i
read yeah aubry's done it he's done it
and what i noticed was he was listening
to me
a little bit like this
you you're in the ufc
if i started talking to you about kung
fu
okay and i was really serious and i
studied kung fu my whole life mm-hmm or
an apkido and shotokan karate you
wouldn't be a dick you'd be like you
know it's got its thing it's you know i
mean you'd be like yeah
yeah but if i started saying that in a
fight what you want to do is you want to
you know you would go you'd be like
polite and you'd listen and you'd be
like i know i don't want to say this
right now
i've seen him do this i don't want to
tell him he's wrong because he won't
understand because he's never been there
yeah do you understand what i'm saying
and so you're you're trying to give
aubrey i think aubry
was i i still i said i said i feel like
i'm talking about things you've
experienced
and it was really interesting because
there was a difference between somebody
who was who had read and heard about
something who's lived it and he lived it
yeah right does that make sense yeah so
that's why
yeah i just thought i'm kind of curious
i'd like to i'd like to have her i'd
like to experience it because when i
read philosophy i go around in a [ __ ]
circle
when i read about religion when i read
the original text i get [ __ ] i'm like
i don't i can't connect do you think
you're thinking more about death because
you're older
no i've always been interested in it
honestly i feel more alive now than i
ever have and i feel better now than i
don't yeah i don't think so
yeah yeah i know you don't at all no but
it's not because it's it's you know i
guess what are you gonna do
yeah you can't control any of it
you do put effort and energy into it you
you you don't and like me you and i
don't think about our past at all like i
don't really you know i don't dwell in
the past i i just don't and some people
really do you know people who remember
dates yeah like in may of 2000 i'm like
i don't [ __ ] know like rain man
but so many people are like that i know
must be nice yeah you get these markers
i remember [ __ ] because of my my new
invisalign
ah but i wonder what the new thing is
looking juicy mark stop it and i'm
liking the thick i like that t-shirt i
said why that thick t-shirt is [ __ ]
great it's a extendo cut so it goes it
goes down covers up the rump a little
bit just gives people a little taste
what size is that is that double
excellent
you know it's actually you can smell
brendan's clone it i stole it from him
he has a photo shoot so yeah i like it
mark yeah i do too mark i'm going to ask
you a serious question if you ask him
dude
i swear to god if you ruin this podcast
listen to me uh five things left to eat
on the planet go
protein what should i be taking a little
insecure right now coming from austin
okay
[Music]
10 pounds of muscle i don't want to be
sluggish
i don't feel like i'm overeating i would
describe it to you but i think the real
solution to this is
we have to train together okay brian we
do we have to film it
show some of the clips on fire in the
kit oh that's not a bad idea okay
fighter and the jacked old guy okay
we could definitely work out and
honestly i was thinking about this the
other day
it can be hard to describe
to people certain things like how do i
look
you can't describe intensity right yeah
act the actual process of putting on
muscle is pretty simple but how do you
convey to somebody you're going to go
until gun to your head you can't do
another one yeah on a deadlift yeah you
know well i'll say this so so tim put me
through this uh obstacle course and i
actually climbed a rope without my legs
i didn't i haven't done that in ten
years but i was surprised but i i was
like let me see if i can do this it was
the morning i wasn't even warmed up but
i climbed all the way out yeah and it
wasn't a long road easy it was hard it
was easy for me if i in fact toward the
end i used to drive over a wall or
something no i just had to ring the bell
and toward the end like twice for two
climbs i used my legs only because i
didn't i wasn't warmed up and i was just
afraid i would overdo it yeah but i
could have done it with without a
problem so i'm like i'm in okay shape
for a 5 year old i can climb a rope
without my [ __ ] legs yeah that ain't
gonna get you bigger
everything you know the entire meme of
the fitness industry is do more
complicated novel things and it's better
the actual process of putting on muscle
is slow and boring
and and takes time it just takes time
but it's it is shockingly simple right
that's all i was brandon one time i go
i was talking about putting on muscle
and he goes i i
i put on 20 pounds maybe i put on 15
pounds of muscle took me a year and a
half
i mean yeah right
actual muscle versus
water retention versus i just gained
weight yeah versus whatever you do if
you take any anabolics for example so
guys will think okay i'm taking to
animal and and that i gained 25 pounds
well you're retaining water minerals
you know all these different things so
actual muscle tissue is pretty slow even
enhanced deadbeat beast you look bigger
i do yeah you look
more muscular what's going on i don't
just live in dude are you lifting heart
heavy or same
uh probably last since i've been so busy
i mean before i lived twice a week mark
yeah you still
but again when we go in
we'll still do the heavy stuff you know
so what does that boil down mean
potatoes you could get stronger you know
if you're just benching and dead lifting
it just covers most of your body i do
gotta increase it and i'll be in la for
most of august because we have the tough
mudder coming up and that's not
something you just don't want yeah
you're not training so you're up you're
weightlifting uh cardio yeah but in that
case like doing this novel stuff it's
like circuit training and climbing the
thing all those things do come into
handy you know but i would just consider
that a different goal
you were in uh elementary back then you
used to have to climb to the top of the
the ropes you should climb up that yeah
yeah they stopped doing it because it's
dangerous yeah they put down the soft
mat you climb the [ __ ] up it was so high
as a kid i bet if i went in now i'm like
oh they had a bodybuilder famous
bodybuilder who specialized in getting
people bigger and stuff and you know
what they said they said if you really
want to change your body the most
radical way to do it is deadlift bench
and squat
literally but as many times a week as
you can if i could do one thing
different if i could start over and talk
to 16 year old mark because i was doing
these pro bodybuilder splits where it's
like just on monday and do 30 cents it's
like
do those basics as many times in a week
as you can handle basically yeah before
your body breaks down yeah yeah
no seriously yeah
and then you take then you de-load a
couple weeks and then do it again part
of the part of it takes care of
assistance i've done steroids yes
yeah you would have yeah no if you won't
put on weight steroids right yeah
let's be honest
i don't say this is a complete waste of
everybody's time but i'm not going to do
it you know you do anything i work out i
mean i'm not going to go heavy no it's
not for you you know be funny so is
there do we get brian drinks or anything
what if there's a way to secretly give
him steroids and he doesn't know about
it no i'm gonna i'll i'll do i'll just
hey we got you drink again and it's just
i mean i don't know though because we
never stopped working oh yeah
all right yeah those goose eggs will
start shrinking maybe with some yeah
isn't this just starbucks that's i'm
worried about that it might just be an
old skinny goat it might have to just be
an old skinny goat with the heavy balls
and keep it just like that it's a good
way for you to stick out i think it's a
good way for you to stick out i'm the
way you are when you have to break up
break break up with something like break
a tie with a business relationship or
you know fire somebody whatever it is i
i talk about it and then i do
nothing i do nothing so we should get at
least being skinny's your thing though
being skinny is my yeah
you want to be all big and like thick
like rogan they just look like a
an alley cat version of rogan yeah you
know
you do your thing yeah but let's go
ahead and shave your head and do that
though right yeah shave your head bald
and you get all juicy really go ahead
and do that that'd be funny yeah
shave it bald get juicy still look like
a skinny rogan and still look like a
skinny rogan you're tough yeah tough all
right what do you got jen
uh before i start i got gifts for you
guys you know what yes
the hell is this it's like an animated
picture um oh this is your t-shirt chin
wow
shin
thank you chin
i'm wearing it and to think i was just
about to buy it online
oh thanks mark appreciate that this is
that this is your shirt chin yeah i
helped design it with the into the am
[Music]
it's all about like what i love doing
the most which is so it's like camping
fishing
you have to camp these guitars on there
yeah this image of you beating up a
senior citizen
i just don't get it
that's a cool shirt chin thanks bro
a little camp vibe
yes cool guys
nice [ __ ] tits
it's a nice shirt gin i'll rock that for
sure
i wore it on wednesday
i look good dude
have you been camping lately chin yeah
just like one night or so by yourself no
friends oh word yeah yeah is it weird if
you can by yourself i want to try it
once that frown upon no it's good
i want to try it one day
if you can't by yourself yeah that weird
maybe a little bit i don't know are you
i'll fill you though
are you one bad break away from the
unibomber if you're a camp by yourself
yeah because he went up by himself out
to montana that's kind of like he's
staying there i'll do a one-nighter
that's it yeah that sounds fun do you
announce your one-nighters like i'll be
in
jacksonville wyoming
nope just go there go where do you go
see what we got
uh real quick i'll do these so will
smith finally came out
and apologized the video is just way too
long
yeah it's way too it's yeah but he
apologized to chris rock his brother a
little late though right yeah and also i
feel like hey i think it's late b i
think he realized
that uh how bad it hurt his image and a
pr team so he put this together and told
him to do it because it's get a good
look it's just
where was this the day after yeah
how long ago how far past we've gone by
yeah he um it's been like three months i
like will smith so i love here's my
thing i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i mean
depression slapped the guy all right how
bad do you think it hurt his image like
is he taking all the [ __ ] a lot dude
okay i don't look at him the same
really i i literally do do not care well
yeah i mean i i would go to this movie
yeah if there was hitch too i'm there
front row
i would love that i saw a king movie so
that was good um uh but this is chris
rock like hours after hearing what or
hours after the video came out that
where will smith apologize and this is
him on stage everybody's trying to be a
[ __ ] victim if everybody claims to be
a victim then nobody will hear the real
victims even me getting smacked by
sugar smith i went to work the next day
i got kids
yeah it didn't it didn't it just was
also completely unacceptable anyone who
says words
uh words hurt has never been punched in
the face that's right
you know yeah a little too late oh it
felt like a pr move
and chris is not ready to talk or reach
out and you know maybe he won't reach
out because
he said he needs to argue i don't know
sometimes you do [ __ ] like when you do
stuff it's like
you lost that relationship sorry yeah
too too much i mean you slept yeah in
the one of the biggest stages in the
world yeah it was so late it was so fake
don't wanna you know i don't wanna yeah
they slap them and it's like you you so
embarrassing for chris and it's also
like
he what he said was even bad it's like
bro
keep that same energy with your wife
like she's the one that caused all this
trauma for you what are you talking
about you're blaming your child and all
this [ __ ] like bro you made the decision
to marry that lady and stick with her
and then chris rock makes it it wasn't
even a good road changer g.i jones what
a gig he didn't know she had alopecia he
didn't know that no one does that's an
excuse
nobody does it doesn't even look like
she has that no i i'm not by
me neither
i'm not either i'm not buying any of it
so it's like and she looks she couldn't
look better with a shaved head yeah i
think she's hottest [ __ ] shaved i
like her long hair but but it's like
okay but i think she looks amazing in
that so it's like
the whole thing was you took a [ __ ] on
on the world and you just got to deal
with it i also think it's tough for will
smith too right because
jdp and smith i mean let's be real you
know
she was with tupac right like that was
her main love and she still talks about
him he posts about him disrespectful of
her i'll agree 100 i'm like okay cool
like you did that to me you were 22.
lady like move on if you're my wife and
the mother my kids and you start talking
about a guy like that
because you're threatened by my
celebrity and it hasn't you have not
you have not become a star she's a star
but she's not a star she's agreeing like
her no no she's not will smith she's not
in his area
and she presents that and clearly and in
my opinion like you're you've you've
upped your profile by being basically
inappropriate about your private life
that's not cool to him well you're
saying she'll disrespect me i'd be like
hey you you can get the [ __ ] out of here
youtube like if you go go [ __ ] like
how much have i done something i'd be
like go rub your titties at tupac in
another house how about that also you're
not gonna be doing this red table talk
talking [ __ ] about me with my daughter
every friday in my [ __ ] kitchen
that's unbelievable how about you take
this toxic tv show on facebook
and go somewhere and get a savage using
my house doing all this [ __ ] right
right also get over tupac you were 20.
but for will like you like you're living
under that shadow all the time and
you're will smith you're dealing with
somebody who will do i'm sure jada
pinkett smith has got a lot of great
qualities i have no doubt
maybe mostly but there's make no mistake
i've been in this business for 30
[ __ ] years
women like that i've been around them
and men there are men just like it so
it's just not a woman man thing but that
person
is will to whatever it takes for
attention and when the attention starts
going somewhere else they will do [ __ ]
that will shock you that's why you can
only have one head shot in the household
that's what he said but also let's talk
about this the the reason why will smith
freaked out all right she has the red
table talk where she just talks she
drags him under the [ __ ] bus every
thursday whenever there's just all their
[ __ ] he's on there crying and stuff it's
[ __ ] that right so then also
they decided to be in an open she
she not only [ __ ] another dude but
brought him on the family vacation to
hawaii that's outrageous well
is that true yeah is that really true
and you talk about it first of all if
that's your kink keep that [ __ ] to
yourself you talk about that everywhere
you went public you're out of your
[ __ ] mind
i'd lose money and you have kids all
right all for what for six clicks for
the show would be a deal break for me
then you're [ __ ] another dude
bringing hawaii on family vacation so
that's strike two do we know that for a
fact
uh that's i think she explained oh this
is table talk yeah
i'm not this isn't are you are you
[ __ ] me you guys don't know about
this i heard about it but i want to make
sure it's nice
am i here is this bro
no no not at all bro news
are we are you [ __ ] me nobody knows
this it is ah
chin bring it up i remember
and also bring up
what was that dude's name though
augustus augustus
yeah i mean this is yeah these are facts
all sorts
even augustus came out and they brought
on the red carpet
sanctioned defense she's saying will
knew about it yeah yeah but don't go
public about that [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up because everyone was
giving a gust of [ __ ] and he's like hold
on we'll knew about this yeah and i
don't have any problems look if those
guys want to [ __ ] do their thing
they've made this relationship work god
bless them but you're going [ __ ]
public with this it's it's really bad
but but also in fact do you have to do
it in hawaiian family vacation hey honey
it's
thursday i'll be right back let me get
banged out by this younger dude he's a
stud too by the way he's all right but
also it's like compared to will smith
he has an angel's tattoo on his neck
dude so he what is he uh he's a singer
okay what were you going to say about it
mm-hmm yeah
atlanta a's or something the oakland a's
okay okay all right let's turn it down
okay hold on let's not assume i'm going
to talk about in regards to what
happened in the world and i have an
opener tonight i'm addressing this here
because a very important side of
everyone
so she said something i guess that got
people talking about it
right that's what i think it is but look
at it so
bt works together
together so
that was her main man but uh august came
out and was like i sat down with will
and he told me it was okay we got his
blessings
so you know but yeah but either way so
you get the red table talk that's deal
breaker bringing homeboy your side piece
to hawaii on the family vacation deal
breaker and then you know
it's it's just one thing after a [ __ ]
no off
of course will smith finally snapped
yeah and he won't shut then every
[ __ ] whenever
anniversary of his death pops up you're
posting letters from him that he used to
write you know all this [ __ ] of course
will smith snapped yeah finally
now did he do it in the safe safest way
possible and slap a small chris rocky
sure he did what do you have done to
jason mo momoa probably that the problem
is that that is he's still responsible
for actions so it has [ __ ] it doesn't
matter what jada smith did he is
responsible for that [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] so
weird
and then also the thing about will smith
thinks think how much [ __ ] will has done
in his career right think about all the
stuff will has done for his image stuff
like this and then jada goes hey i'm
gonna do red table talk and air out all
our dirty laundry
everything and you're like whoa you know
how hard i've worked in show business
since i was a teenager to build this
[ __ ] platform and then you're just
gonna take it down because you want
something to do
are you [ __ ] me yep
yep
wow
that's 50 cent i'm will smith
oh my gosh
and she said then she said only she can
give permission for somebody to blow up
her back out damn [ __ ] you 50.
wait what is a bit of a troll yeah so
who knows if that's right wait who said
that that was 50 cents 50 cent come on
dude
come on
so it's a dm right no from 50 that's 50
to will smith
this stuff is
very old he's joking around about it
though [ __ ] you 50 is like no that's
that's here so you haven't talked to him
since oh
yeah but 50 and i don't know i posted
that but wow
that's weird too the whole thing's
[ __ ] weird man going public with [ __ ]
is [ __ ] weird to me but again
right everyone's talking about jada now
she's the life of the party and
if you're will you're like what in the
[ __ ] how hard i've worked and how my
reputation's ruined because i slapped
chris rock
all the work i've done on him that's on
him agree but a lot of it's her just
take ownership too
and the way she looked at him like
mm-hmm
you know on thursday i'm gonna talk [ __ ]
right so he's like i better slap
she's not gonna take ownership for
anything nothing nothing well they're
both and then then the pr team's like
all right
say you have uh
alopecia like that's why you're so
defensive over here okay i guess what is
that it's where you can't grow here okay
that works they're still together i
personally love
will smith and he [ __ ] up but love
chris rock too so yeah i don't know yeah
you pay a price
that's where it is okay what else got
you all right this is a crazy one
there's this uh british student 22 years
old christ so
like they were flying to the greek
islands and then they all left the
helicopter but this guy came back for
whatever reason with his phone and it
was a it was the actual back blades so
apparently
the bones on the tail yeah but
apparently you can't really see them
when they're going
well he said they said that he was
walking with his phone and then it just
it's probably tech's head hustle yeah
he's probably texting or not something
like that but he was like what's up fam
yeah what's up family we helicopter
such a bad situation there were thoughts
that maybe he was trying to do a selfie
but then
but the investigations all the time
investigators are saying that uh no it
doesn't okay
this never happens no no no no no one
runs into a blade of hell no people do
oh no no no no no there are a lot of
people you can actually see it on
youtube
that one rich guy who was on his phone
walking towards it boom gets hit right
not all the time
not all the time 24 7 dude
very very rare what i'm saying is it
happens i'm not saying it happens more
than 100 times a day but it does happen
under a hundred times a day do this kid
[ __ ] just doing his thing on social
media brandon a helicopter we're all
going we're all going and sometimes you
go in the [ __ ] weirdest ways it's
just we're not all going and also
helicopters you don't want to go by
you're doing a social media posting
getting your head chopped off by a
helicopter blade that's why we don't
know if he was doing that though
they're trying to contact his friends
the investigators but all the friends
apparently have their phones off and
it's kind of weird he went with friends
so they're trying to investigate it but
they're getting no help to figure out
exactly what happened damn so he was
pushed maybe and they're like let's just
not respond to anybody
yeah jesus christ man pretty crazy
you know you're getting close to this
thing it's like it's all so loud
i'll show you one more that's pretty
crazy we can't show you the video but
this is you know those big jumbo screens
on stage yeah the big ones one fell on
top of a dancer in hong kong killed him
uh paralyzed for now he's paralyzed but
they're trying to get his nerves to you
know grow back but i could not believe
how
this is just
horrific you can say that about every
quadriplegic this is in hong kong not
his nerves look at that oh
no
rewind there's people that are rewinding
it looks like a movie right it looks
like he's dead how's how did that not
kill him
now for those viewers just listening it
crushes his from his neck up yeah it's
like chest neck up
oh
[ __ ] that's terrible yeah and then oh
then that one hit the other sucks
that was insane to watch
everybody
jesus christ hopefully be better about
securing [ __ ] your dumb screens
although we see it all the time
that happens
all the time that's your catchphrase it
happens all the time oh it does
it happens all the time i mean that one
it's just
let's go individually god dawg you know
what that's like final destination movie
[ __ ]
you know my neighbor one time had cancer
and her head was shaved she had a she
had her i didn't know her she had she
was wrapped yeah my but my other
neighbor knew her
and i said
same thing i go
damn man it's so terrible and he just
went he's coming on his voice he's older
he goes people beat it all the time they
beat her all the time
i was like they don't though
see we can't say that
they do though
cancer more people eat cancer than get
hit by helicopters right
that's true i guess they beat all that
oh yeah i like how you do when you have
a real real big problem anybody goes ah
you'll figure it out manuel what what i
have a bit about that's the
that's your advice
uh you got this no i don't no no no
actually i don't that's why i'm
in tears
trying to figure this out
oh hey bro come on you got this man you
you always figure it out don't worry
about it it's going to work out i don't
figure it out and this is a big issue i
say it all the time i have a whole joke
about it trust the universe trust the
universe god is good it's going to work
out god is good that does nothing for me
no see oh you forgot i have kids i have
to provide and protect yeah so
that's not how it works it can go very
bad it can go worse than you imagine but
also dude tough times don't last tough
people do
excuse me ah thanks a lot doctor no help
i call those people doctor no help
whatever i did here hang in there i
heard a muslim scholar say
oh this is what you do when shit's going
bad
alhamdulillah meaning thank you thank
you god
because
it could always be way worse he said the
two things to the patience gratitude
patience and gratitude no matter what
hard to do you know what i'd rather you
say ah you'll figure it out then tell me
that harder to the guy with the
helicopter head right because he's worse
could be worse
well the guy with the thing fell on
could be worse
really what's worse than this dude i
can't move now i just be dancing be
raining
could be raining this could have fell on
you and it could be raining so you see
what i'm saying
horrible advice also that does also
nothing sometimes did you ever see the
[ __ ]
what's it called uh the sea inside with
javier bardem
well sir it's a story about a guy who
dives off a cliff becomes completely
paralyzed can't move and he's like this
he's only a head and they have to rotate
him and stuff and he lives in a room and
i was like this is not the movie
i don't care how inspiring i ain't
watching it no no because you know what
happens in the end you basically die so
i'm not interested in that
what else you got
mark what do you got marcus okay let's
try to play some of these
what is it
a cool video
cool video you guys have never seen
patience everybody
for your safety i strongly suggest you
do the same get all your friends around
call every friend you have right now all
of them invite them out for a party when
they all turn up pour out sparkling
water pour it all out see everyone let's
have a glass of water together water
can't hurt anybody we're all probably
dehydrated anyway what's the worst water
can do everyone let's have a nice glass
of water and everyone's going to drink
it when you see that one dude oh
there's bubbles never speak to him again
[Music]
we play from the warren time marks he's
[ __ ] hilarious this guy yeah he's
blowing up right he's like i'm a world
champion kickboxer yeah i think so
[ __ ] love him um i love that
for your safety i strongly suggest you
do the same get all your friends around
call every friend you have right now all
of them invite them out for a party when
they all turn up party sparkling water
pour it all out see everyone let's have
a glass of water together water can't
hurt anybody we're all probably
dehydrated anyway what's the worst water
can do everyone let's have a nice glass
of water and everyone's going to drink
it when you see that one dude oh
there's bubbles never speak to him again
he's so funny too he's got a great sense
of humor a great sense of humor he's
also like
this alpha male who just has no
censorship the best which we don't see
at all a lot of truth which we don't see
at all these days drops a lot of truth
what's crazy tim talk about yeah this is
a funny clip from this podcast that i
thought was relevant to our conversation
today
tim's the funniest guy ever do is build
a luxury compound in austin texas where
every single house has its own podcast
studio and comedy club
every house
so every like 15 000 square foot house
has a comedy club in it where rich
psychopaths can pretend to be comedian
why not
she was talking about these massive
developments and how they like
uh will
trick you to invest in these huge like
you know crazy developments like oh leo
they give leo you know dicaprio a house
and then they're like take a picture of
him at the corner like leo lives here
yeah don't you billionaires want to live
here and then they make these huge
developments yeah it's like why haven't
we done this in austin and then that was
his take yeah
yep
so there was another death in the
bodybuilding community yesterday this
guy better known oh i remember this guy
he passed away at the age of 55. he was
kind of an internet viral have you seen
him brad
he put oil in his biceps and muscles
like oil he posted about him just a
couple days ago saying he isn't planning
on stopping injecting synthol anytime
soon if you google the word synthol on
google images his picture is literally
the first thing that comes up now while
this is sad it's another cautionary tale
you got to be careful what you put in
your body so just remember that
no no no yeah i remember i don't need a
cautionary tale that's crazy he told me
not to he had body dysmorphia for sure
right yeah like to put synthol in his
body
sad take on it would be he couldn't
afford other things and that was his way
of getting big yeah and he had some sort
of body dysmorphia there's something
wrong with him he was a little bit let's
say but body just morphing and also
broke so he could put you know that
stuff in him
oh this is great debra king is doing his
first ever reaction video to the joe
rogan andrew schubert podcast because
joe rogan is talking about number kick
and nobody and i mean nobody attacks the
king with impunity
maybe joe rogan but that doesn't mean i
have to take it late down let's watch
and react to this next clip
do you know how rare it is to have a
physique like that and not be on
steroids you would have to be in the
zero zero zero zero zero point one
percent of the human population just
so you're saying there's a chance
[Laughter]
i love him see but that's my thing too
like i think he's great i i'll say
steroids a lot of times but i'm telling
you dude there's i've seen some guys who
are just [ __ ] the freaks yeah that's
great i don't care if he found stars
he's awesome oh i could care less i
don't care i love it i also don't know i
literally don't know i'm not even
interested i wouldn't even ask him i
don't give a [ __ ] that's when rogan says
001 percent i
i i i don't know i've seen it man i've
seen every team i've been on there's
that guy you're like what the [ __ ] dude
well look at klopp
that's
they're our body you can you can look at
certain bodies and
but if you've seen pictures of him young
like you're just his physique like he
was jack i've seen him can i say on on
the two opposite sides of the genetic
spectrum you could have
the worst genetics for putting on muscle
and take 10 years of high doses
and still not be as muscular as somebody
who's on the opposite end who's never
taken anything so there isn't like you
know there's an overlap of all
everything in between well i think
there's a you know there's
misinformation as far as steroids go
it's like if you know people look at the
rock or you look at arnold
schwarzenegger you've seen arnold or the
rock when they're 14 yeah i mean
the just the framework they're working
on they're already freaks yeah and
steroids might help them 10 or 15
percent freeze too but you're not
getting you forget if you're on that end
that low end of the genetic spectrum
you're putting on muscle mass and even
just the aesthetic because part of why
we like arnold is his arms are a certain
length and his waist is a certain size
he's always been that way yeah you're
never killing you can take having
tim tebow i'm telling tim
i would see the way he'd work out and
if i would assume if you just filmed his
workouts and people like there's no way
somebody can work out that hard and not
be on steroids like no i've seen it yeah
tim tebow yeah i mean he's a freak
you know arguably the best college
football player of all time so yeah he's
an outlier but i'm telling you if
there's guys but there are also guys tim
kennedy they're all three guys in
baseball they're also guys
who are like bodybuilders who would be
40 pounds lighter
uh if they weren't taking steroids right
so even if they have a frame
the steroids will put and you can look
at the yankees in the 90s i don't give a
[ __ ] what anybody says jason jambi and
all those guys they were 40 pounds barry
bonds 40 pounds right 50 pounds heavier
yeah than they would normally be and
that's also doing it right too because a
lot of people do it extremely
haphazardly and you end up worse off
than you started because you do it for a
few weeks and then you stop you don't
take the right thing so yeah you know
that's systematic the other thing all
those guys mention are high high elite
athletes that's the other thing they're
also natural muscles they're also not
starting from grounds correct and they
also can put muscle they're getting
easier than most yeah so those steroids
joe and then also oh it's like
fertilizer
that's right
that's exactly right that's something
people never forget about so a lot of
times they say well this is sammy sosa
he was also 19 and he wasn't lifting
weights
you take a guy like that and now he's 25
and he's been lifting weights and eating
and stuff he's already gonna he's gonna
blow up he's already gonna be super much
michael's right i think mark where i got
like 280 pounds so i'm like not that big
a bat he's a freak but also he's a big
dude man big big [ __ ] dude
what else you got very big guy
okay so this is uh from uri faber's new
fight league i guess
they're gonna do i don't know if sound
fight oh
did they stop the fight no they didn't
they let them go eventually they stopped
it though right yeah they did holy [ __ ]
what does that feel like
i've never broken my nose that bad in
the middle of a fight but they should
definitely stop it because the guy's
getting paid 600 right so it's like
i if it's a title fight yeah let him let
him do his thing but that you got to
stop it
is it state again this is my boy tate
stop talking to people because they were
tired a lot they're always wanting that
i'm like bro why are you always napping
you know i'm just tired well then you're
just a low-energy lethargic idiot it's
just a nap no it's not just a nap all of
us other men are up and we have things
to do and even if we are tired we're not
going to mention it we're just going to
continue to function none of these
people are around me we're not going to
mention it strap if you're napping you
can't pull the strap if you're having a
heart attack tough it up
[Music]
he's hilarious you can't pull the strap
shutting it down for 20 minutes i can't
say it when you're like in the middle
they're like i'm just going to take your
naps like yeah
it is two in the afternoon yeah what are
you from what from what have you been
doing
if i don't need a nap why do you need it
if i've slept my seven hours i'm good
if i've slept less than that i might and
i got a show that night i'll i'll shut
it down for about 20 minutes okay i mean
yeah if i don't sleep well or something
and i'm at the airbnb we're doing
nothing yeah but if that's just i don't
tell people about it though i'm not i
had a great i don't want to hear about
it never say that oh dude my dad here
older get it and you know he's not he's
been around his grandkids so he's
chasing him
a nap at 11 which i was like you just
okay woke up at eight eleven okay a nap
at four o'clock well aren't you gonna go
to bed like eight because i take two
naps oh man
and then i i don't know what it is it's
triggering to when my girl i'll come in
and she's real tired again what's wrong
with you she's like i'm just tired
you're tired when people tell me how
tired they are it's so true i'm like
you're tired um
okay so but you're not like this because
you're tired and she's like yeah i'm
just tired all right cool there's
nothing more triggering why i don't know
it drives me nuts
when people tell me how tired they're
i'm like
what
excuse me i've been slept right in six
weeks [ __ ] you're tired
have i said anything i suffer from major
have i said anything
take a stimulant
there's so many things you can do take
adderall right now anything yeah okay
here's another take clip this is going
to be taped heavy today
he had jade on his podcast
i shaved my head i could have hair i
deliberately try and have no hair why
you ain't got here you're a chick
nothing to say
dang will's fault the whole world
dislikes you jada even like the normies
fair enough the people outside the
matrix like me we understand who the
good guys and the bad guys are but when
the normies know you're the bad guy
you're really messing up
everybody likes you
this guy is [ __ ]
[ __ ] hilarious
did i click that [ __ ] he actually got
he's like nobody liked you was he a k1
fighter what was that i i know he's
world champion stud yeah yeah it's so
funny though he's all he's all when the
he goes when the guys outside the matrix
like me don't like he was but when the
normies it's [ __ ] hilarious one more
thing casuals
this is tate again boy a car right he
crashes
bro [ __ ] up i'm gonna pay this off i'm
gonna get to work i'll get another job
man i'm sorry
[ __ ] crashes your car well it wasn't
even my fault that guy came out of
nowhere i didn't even know
just buy a new one and i can't afford it
and then and if you get too tough to her
look you better [ __ ] pay she's just
gonna block you and [ __ ] some other guy
he crashes your boy crashed the car it's
so cute the guy's like dude oh i didn't
see coming i [ __ ] up oh don't worry
i'll pay you back yeah he's right girls
are like well you know remember remember
when lex [ __ ] up my car oh my god he
hit a motorcycle or something like that
my manager like he's been my manager
since five how many years now when i
start fighting he's been my manager for
11 12 years forever forever since ufc is
my major now entertainment forever he's
been the most loyal guy in my team for
forever great guy he worked does all the
deals for me today
lex has bad vision lex is
legally blind at the time he's had lasik
now but he was
no i'm not lying i'm not trying to make
that dude blind in both eyes legally
blind can't see you i couldn't see
dude bro
when uh anderson silva knocked out uh
when he knocked out vitor belford with
the front kick the remember the front
kick
we're
cage side ufc gave me case side tickets
he said next to me guys that's the best
night i've ever seen he goes what
happened he's looking
at the cage i go what are you excuse me
because
tell me what happened
dude you use your [ __ ] eyes he goes i
can't even see in there i'm like and you
use the ticket so this is the guy
dude listen to this bike he comes here
and uh he didn't have a car brian goes
oh brian had a new passat or volkswagen
yeah and brian goes oh you just take my
car oh b don't do that don't give me a
car he said that brian goes no it'll be
fine dude he can't see brian goes no
it'd be fine
an hour later hit a guy on a motorcycle
he ran over a guy on a motorcycle ruined
brian's car
the guy was fine the guy like
like it was like so hard for him because
he's such a stand-up guy and of course i
was like i don't give a [ __ ] as long as
you're okay and the guy on the
motorcycle is okay that's what matters
it's a [ __ ] car yeah but it was just
so funny man he paid for it and
everything no he's the best marine like
you know a marine
struggling with like accepting the fact
that he can't no no i think he might be
probably made from being a veteran maybe
i forget what happened to his eyes he
has some condition with the retinas but
he's had surgery now so now his
division's perfect oh nice back then he
comes when i went to brazil to do promo
before i fought in aguero yeah this
brazilian takes on this hike on this
mountain
when we started in the morning and uh
that night we're at dinner this
home-cooked dinner in like this cool
like little hut and the favelas his
family's cooking for some best food i've
ever had everyone's so sweet sitting on
the ground
their floors are dirt we're sitting on
the ground and he goes uh fellas
tomorrow i'm gonna take you on the hike
we do it's very challenging and we start
at 7am so make sure you guys get rest
tonight and i go 7 a.m can we do it like
10 or so many days we can't because
once the night comes that mountain's not
safe i go oh like jaguars and he's like
i felt stupid he's like people he's like
it it's not safe we have to get up and
down by before the sun falls if the sun
falls you're giving me some trouble he's
like
everybody knows that around here so just
give some time it's probably gonna take
around four to five hours to hike this
mountain so we'll start early it might
take longer to depend how fast we move
we show up the next morning everyone's
ready to go i got my shoes tied on tight
i'm not making this up this dude tall
brazilian six four six five black belt
jiu jitsu he's in a sunga right sing up
big dick sunga you can see just see this
big [ __ ]
acai [ __ ] dick right in this thing
no shoes
hiking up a [ __ ] mountain right stud
so we're going it's some other [ __ ]
monsters from the ufc we're going
and he and lex is you know lex is rotant
he's actually he's a big strong guy very
strong yeah but anyways you know he's
not in shape he's wrote dude we're going
not fat
barrel chested he has some extra weight
but he's big he wouldn't say he's in
shape that's what i'm trying to say so
um
so he's we're going up the mountain and
it's like we're two hours in lights
falling way behind and like brazilian
girls hey brandon can't talk to you i
know what's up because we're not gonna
make it if we're waiting for lex so can
we say somewhere can we try and motivate
him because we're not gonna make it i'm
telling you dude i can't emphasize
enough we have to get out it started to
scare me like i'm telling you we have to
get going before the sun comes down like
holy [ __ ] so he goes maybe you know him
best you go talk to him so you rather
hey lex dude
the whole group like we we'd be way
further dude but we're kind of pacing
ourselves with you and he goes amigo
go on without me i'll be fine i go dude
he's saying if you don't get it down by
sundown we're [ __ ] next goes amigo i'm
telling you i'll make it i'll be fine
before sundown we're like okay and i go
to the i go he said go on he was really
and he goes dude i'm make sure he's down
for sundown i go he's he's a marine
he'll figure it out dude if not he can
just turn around and so i go hey lex if
you want just turn around when we
finally have to worry he goes i got it
go i'm gonna keep going though
we go takes us five hours we barely make
it by sundown
lex goes missing
for two nights two nights two nights
holy [ __ ] two nights what happened they
sent out a search crew everything what
happened oh i'm glad you asked well what
happened is he got so dangerous
he it was like eight o'clock at night
pitch black
in the brazilian forest dude he can't
see and he can't see bruh dude brian oh
he can't see anyway big so he's he's
trying to figure his way out he sees a
little hut there's a fire in there
whatever he goes in there and lady
gravel what are you doing
get in here barely spoke english brought
him in there he stayed with them they
fed his big ass he just was like yeah
he's chilled man
i'm like dude we we thought you died
we thought he died of course we i was
like oh lex died yeah next time he died
two days later wow let me go i'm like
you're alive the gas and brazilian
family took me in bro
ate great food slept great awesome yeah
went to the waterfall like dude
we thought you were dead no amigo still
here he always says amigo amigo
still here [ __ ] yeah dude that's insane
so funny have you been back to brazil
since no great great place though
amazing amazing place yeah yeah
i don't know if you've seen this one
before but uh
you seen this one
well they all these guys got to rob him
leave the car and he pushes it over
oh they shoot oh [ __ ] shoot they have
guns
because that's not a little you know
there's a long way to go before you get
on that freeway
and they're just lighting them up
do you think you'd do the same thing and
that's 100 percent yeah let me see i'm
going through this again now the problem
is if you're not in a big car you meet
you're in some trouble if you're in a
ferrari or porsche it's so low you're
not gonna yeah he's lucky he's gonna be
tough whatever truck he's in a truck or
suv
god they're he must have wanted a
murderer there's a clip in the [ __ ]
looks like they were trying to kill him
or something yeah more than just a
carjacking that seems more than a
robbery or maybe they're
and that dude must have known right he's
like if i don't do this right now she's
gonna get murdered nice man
yeah they were gonna rob me and probably
kill him jesus christ this is collectors
rob collectors
i'm sorry that those kids i'm sorry
those guys didn't get run over by the
truck that would have been good i don't
know if they caught those guys i mean
the car's damaged so they'll get the
license plate all that stuff
that's true yeah and you could get the
license before he pulls up yeah that's
close enough i don't know whether it
doesn't look like they're in america
right they just they just they just
report it missing yeah so the last thing
i had um
ryan i don't think you'd seen mike all
stop play brendan has this new jersey my
boy so uh matrion right he did food
truck a.m shoes and he's like you're a
big mike all-star fan right and uh matt
played with mike alston like you know
matt knows mike also because he went to
purdue together he's like he's my boy
and he's i'm gonna get you a signed
jersey everyone tells me all sorts of
i'm like okay dude
he said that like three months ago and
then where at companion he got there and
before you i go where the [ __ ] my
jersey goes
i was gonna wait you son of a [ __ ] but
here it is and [ __ ]
got the exact one man
well then this is their old school
old school tampa bay buccaneers yeah
mike alstott and so also uh uh wow the
dope the guy who made him famous with
the boom
chris yeah uh
beerman yeah chris berman chris berman
gun whoop whoop whoop and me and my
younger brother were obsessed with
michael i said we wear his jerseys every
young like white kid was yeah he was the
white running back right yesterday
[Applause]
look at him and he was fast but more so
just impossible to take that right okay
oh he was so funny pull back a running
back full back full back yeah
look at him you make that at least
footwork filthy
and they call it thunder and lightning
yeah they're a great one-two combo
oh my god you don't have anybody like
this now closest is henry for the titans
look around look at the speed first size
that's crazy and again
oh my god how old is he now
oh man has to be 50.
four bit mid 40s imagine how much this
was like what was the guy who played for
the redskins uh
john um riggins john riggins
remember him
i don't because i'm young right yeah
reagan's is the same exact way
wow oh 48 play for the purdue
boilermakers
out of west lafayette indiana
and then there's one where there's a
little youtube short that i linked there
that gave a little bit about his story
if you're interested tiki barber was
getting into acting and stuff
yeah but he really was getting into it i
don't know what happened to him can you
well he got a job no no he's an analyst
oh yeah he went down that road yeah okay
he has a podcast does the analyst work
for nfl okay yeah
he like had a major job with like fox
nfl yeah yeah he's crazy probably like
[ __ ] acting i'm gonna take all the money
and do
they make so much money they do yeah
yeah okay if you're a big-time analyst
yeah that's such a dude you have you you
he probably made a lot of money in his
career right would you say yeah
yeah yeah uh
a uh a twin brother who also played
quarterback yep ron day barber yeah
rondae that's right
that's why i saw it yeah
93 million okay not bad um
i mean he was such a baller wow yeah
he's a big time player man
big time player wow his brother's
[ __ ] saw it too
there's one more clip on mike allstate
any interest in seeing it what is it
it's like it's a short that covers a
little bit more of his life but it's
like a minute long that's okay we
probably won't be able to play it
yeah that's on youtube
but i share the same passion for mike
also that you do
oh my god he was good it's being a
passion i'm in baltimore this thursday
friday saturday
baltimore this thursday friday saturday
then one night only chicago den theater
august 26th
appleton wisconsin haven't been there
because it's a great club have you been
there appleton sure haven't it's a great
is it fun yes it's [ __ ] that's
september 8th through the 10th that's
almost sold out then we just added
ontario and proven my favorite club
clubs ontario improv september 15th to
the 17th then boston you're probably
thinking wilbur wrong first time ever
boston uh laugh boston great club laugh
boston september 29th through october
1st get you some boston tickets at
thickboy.com that's got the new merch
mark was rocking it now he's in chin
shirt that's okay uh we have the thick
boy tie-dye and thick boy white tees
tanks and the trucker hats thickboy.com
nashville tennessee zany's august 26-27
it's gonna be awesome san jose
california the improv september 15 16 17
specan washington
spokane uh comedy club september 22 24
tacoma washington tacoma comedy club
september 29 to august 1st
it's going to be what we call lit
liddy like a titty lady like a teddy all
right y'all love you see ya